[موسيقى]
بعد التلويح بالنووي تدريبات الروسيه على
صواريخ يارس العابره للقارات
الشوارع في فرنسا تتحول لساحه حرب بين
المحتجين والشرطه
نهايه سعيده لقضيه الطفل شنوده في مصر
هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من قناه
العربيه اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
بعد ايام من التلويح باستخدام النووي بدات
موسكو مناورات وتدريبات على اطلاق صواريخ
باليستيه نوويه عابره للقارات من طراز
يارس بمشاركه ثلاثه الاف جندي ونحو
ثلاثمائه قطعه عسكريه وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه اعلنت ان المناورات شملت الثلاث
مناطق من البلاد فيما يعد صاروخ يارس من
اقوى الصواريخ الباليستيه الروسيه حيث يصل
مداه لنحو 12 الف كيلو متر ما يمنحه
القدره على اصابه ابعد المواقع في العالم
فضلا عن قوته التفجيريه الهائله
ساحه حرب حقيقيه تحولت اليها شوارع فرنسا
في اليوم العاشر من الاحتجاجات ضد قانون
التقاعد الجديد الشرطه اعتقلت عشرات من
المتظاهرين واطلقت الغاز المسيله للدموع
فيما رد المتظاهرون باغلاق الطرق واشعال
النيران رقعه الاحتجاجات اتسعت لتضم
العديد من المدن بينها العاصمه باريس كما
شملت الاضرابات القطاعات العماليه
والتعليميه اضافه الى قطاع السياحه واذ
اغلقت رموز فريسه السياحيه مثل قصر فيرساي
وبرج ايفل ابوابها امام الزوار
نهايه سعيده لملف شائك اثار الكثير من
الجدل في مصر وهي قضيه الطفل شنوده حيث
امرت النيابه العامه المصريه بتسليم الطفل
الى العائله التي عثرت عليه وتبنتها بعد
ان اخذت تعهدا بحسن رعايته تسليم الطفل
جاء بعد ان استططلعت النيابه العامه راي
مفتي الجمهوريه باتباع الطفل ديانه
العائله المسيحيه التي وجدته وبالتالي
اسقاط الحكم الذي غير ديانته الى مسلم
وغير اسمه من شنوده الى يوسف
الى عالم التكنولوجيا وفي استراليا تحديدا
حيث انشا فنان يدعى
تجربه لمحاكاه لحظات شبيهه بالموت عبر
الواقع المعزز احد الذين خاضوا التجربه
اوضح انه استلقى على سرير يهتز وراى
الاطباء يفشلون في انعاشه بعد تعرضه لسكته
قلبيه مضيفا انه ومن خلال الرؤيه
الافتراضيه بدا وكانه يصعد الى الاعلى
وراء جسده في الاسفل وكانه جثه ممدده على
السرير فيما وصف خبراء هذه التجربه
بالخطيره
وفي حادثه ماساويه لقيت ملكه جمال
برازيليه مصرعها بعد ان قفزت من شرطه
شقتها في الطابق السادس هربا من حريق
التهم منزلها بحسب ما نقلت صحيفه مترو
البريطانيه الشابه ما يرى نيتاو ذات ال27
عاما توفيت في المستشفى متاثره بالاصابه
البالغه التي تعرضت لها وسبق ان توجت ملكه
الجمال البرازيليه بتسعه القاب بمسابقات
جمال منذ العام 2019 اخرها كان في يناير
الماضي
[موسيقى]